as you finish her holiday shopping we've
got a warning for you today if you're
getting your gifts online many people
are being scammed by questionable ads on
social media like Instagram some
products never arrived others turn out
to be different than what you saw
advertised and a Warner shows us what to
look out for online tis the season and a
good night right yeah good morning and
almost all those ads in question come
from companies you've never heard of
before promoting deep discounts are they
small businesses trying to attract new
customers or are they scammers trying to
turn a quick buck it can be difficult to
differentiate the two they got me on
that one it was the promise of a great
deal that Raul Gonzalez says prompted
him to order a drone that popped up in
his Instagram feed in October a company
called military tease said they'd marked
down an $800 combat drone to just a
hundred bucks but the supposedly
high-quality drone arrived in a plastic
bag from China who smashed no say what's
this so I pulled it out looked at I'm
like whoa that's not what I ordered it's
very light light and flimsy and not
quality I was expecting the drone does
fly but when he demonstrated it for us
the battery started dying after just a
couple minutes that's it that's as long
as it goes not only is it not the
high-end model Gonzalez expected he says
it's not even worth what he paid for it
he found the drone available elsewhere
for under 50 bucks and when he contacted
the company he says military T's
wouldn't provide a refund I'm trying to
go about this a nice way you guys aren't
going about the nice way I'm gonna file
a complaint against you guys he's not
the only one complaining says Catherine
Hutt with the Better Business Bureau
it's hard to tell on social media
advertising what's real and what's not
and unfortunately a lot of the ads are
fake she says some of the ads feature
photos of real high quality products but
what the scammers are selling are cheap
knock-offs
the snowblower one shopper thought he
ordered turned out to be an ice scraper
two other people told us they thought
they'd purchased motorized surfboards
but instead got foam boogie boards that
says do your research
because a good ad looks like a bad ad
yeah they both look good the scammers
use the same tactics that legitimate
sales people use they they know what
works and that's what they use anyone
can start a website and look like a
company in five minutes
artist Jenny O'Dell learned how some of
those companies work while researching
these watches as part of an art project
they're sold at deep discounts on
Instagram the stores looked hip and
trendy but a lot of the wording was you
know copy pasted from other web sites
and a lot of the imagery was just stock
imagery Odell found the people behind
those companies we're actually doing
what's called drop shipping setting up
what looks like a store selling its own
products online but instead simply
acting as a middleman marketing items
from manufacturers often in China those
overseas companies then shipped directly
to the customer the drop shipper doesn't
design or manufacture the items or even
hold any inventory so you think that
you're on a unique boutique site
somebody who's curated a really cool
collection of clothes or shoes or
accessories and really what you're doing
is you're just purchasing from a mass
manufacturer who's gonna dropship that
package to you Odelle never found out
who was actually selling those watches
unlike with a regular store she says
pinpointing their location turned out to
be impossible
I think after what I found honestly I
wouldn't buy anything off of Instagram I
don't know maybe I have a more of an
appreciation for brick-and-mortar retail
now because at least you're in a place
and you can see the thing and you can
touch it and you can talk to people Raul
Gonzalez did get his money back but only
after filing a complaint with his credit
card provider
he says military tees didn't even want
the drone back he discovered many others
had similar complaints about the company
Instagram banned their ads and their
website is no longer working they never
responded to our request for comment
it's wrong it should be illegal it's
like you know saying I'm selling you a
Jaguar and giving you a pin oh I mean
it's the same thing
we asked Instagram to sit down with us
the company declined to do an on-camera
interview but told us that every ad gets
screened before it's posted with either
human or automated review the company
says that review allows it to catch most
of the policy violating ads but that
it's continuously working to improve
since some still managed to slip through
now a couple of things to look out for
the biggest red flag of course too good
to be true price if it's dramatically
lower than that of other sellers hey BBB
says watch out also you should really
look at the website Google the URL to
see if other people are complaining
about that same website and of course
research products before you buy we've
posted some research tips on our website
CBS this morning comm from Instagram on
how to research but research research
it's a great service you performed this
morning I love mr. Gonzales number one
he's smiling the whole time such a
level-headed guy I'm trying to be nice
about this you guys aren't being nice
and then Ana when you held it up and go
this is pretty light so plasticky and
dinky yeah it seems like was all made
out of even the company didn't want it
back I was a Pinto version of a drone
yeah yeah it's me of the guys on the
corner used to sell their watches from
inside their coat you know it's not high
quality merchandise to be true I bought
one of those when I was younger
still working no
[Laughter]